une entrée sous artifices pour un combat
explosif
l'élan courtois a dit la môme a dit
était très attendue pour ce gala de boxe
organisé au vélodrome nationale à
domicile le boxeur de 37 ans n'a pas
déçu ses supporters face un adversaire
solide le champion en titre a dû livrer
un combat acharné pour remporter la
victoire
une victoire finalement acquise auprès
après la limite et qui lui permet de
conserver son titre de champion d'europe
dans la catégorie des poids super moyens
la champion d'europe dans les yvelines
grande fierté et encore merci pour ceux
qui me soutiennent fierté un objectif de
terminer on est parti pour d'autres
objectifs encore le monde à domicile le
champion d'europe a bénéficié d'un
soutien sans faille de ses proches
encouragements écrit ils étaient plus
d'une cinquantaine présents autour du
ring et y avait un bon boxeur en face et
sauf était présent ce soir et les
importants aujourd'hui c'était quasi
lagarde sa ceinture et la veille je le
remercie c'est quelqu'un de courageux on
retient une belle du cordat dit là
c'était un beau combat ce soir et je
pense que tout le monde apprécie il
boxait eux aussi à domicile les membres
de la team farrugia d'elancourt termine
avec un bilan positif
marvin petit a décroché une 22e victoire
en poids super-légers gallus coulon a
remporté lui sa huitième victoire chez
les super légers
c'est vraiment une dizaine belle salle
le vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
ça fait vraiment plaisir de boxer chez
nous devant notre public donc on a je
pense qu'on a été tout se transcender
quelques quelques beaux arts de boxe ici
seul bémol de la soirée la défaite aux
points de marine tollé pour son premier
combat professionnel
au total pour ce premier gala de boxe
organisé au vélodrome national de saint
quentin en yvelines 12 combats étaient
organisées durant toute la soirée de
quoi satisfaire les 6000 spectateurs
c'est un bel endroit je pense programme
reste du monde
c'est top il n'y a pas de gros
événements qui se passent au vélodrome
des événements sportifs donc là c'est
vraiment une belle événements et il faut
que ça continue sans commande changement
de style et et changement d'ambiance le
week-end prochain le vélodrome national
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines accueillera
le championnat de france seniors de judo
[Musique]